the story of syria this past 10 years
begins and it ends with this man
president bashar al-assad
it is the story of an uprising against
him brutally suppressed by him
it's been a war which has changed our
understanding of brutality
it's shifted politics well beyond its
borders
and it has left the country and its
people broken and divided
we're 400 miles from the capital
damascus
amudha is in the northeastern corner of
syria
and we're following muhammad from the
destroyed city of aleppo originally
but here now with his whole family
there are four generations here all 14
of them
sleep where we sit but it's better than
what they left
foreign
in one sense they are the lucky ones
they're in a house not a refugee camp
but then not being in a camp means they
don't have help from charities
the disintegration of a country at war
begins with the death
and the pain but beyond that are the
legacies
on the road east we pass a convoy of
trucks
a resupply chain for the american troops
who are here
these planes of northern syria are now
where the superpowers tussle for control
there's regional influence and oil to
secure
this is the only place in the world
where russian and american militaries
brush past each other
commissioning is a city like the country
divided
most of it under the control of the
kurds now but pockets are still assad's
land
in the souk money changers need carts to
carry their currency
because so much is needed to buy so
little
anything else
in a clamor for currency he is in demand
and spells out the crisis
sir
the devaluation of course has a
devastating effect on salaries
which in the chaos has declared itself
autonomous
[Music]
[Music]
looking for hope here after a decade of
war is hard
but you can find it on the faces of the
young
who will pick up the pieces mark stone
sky news
in syria